[Applaudissements]
j'adore c'est la folie ce soir allez
encore nous c'est bon on en fera
d'autres ne vous inquiétez pas tout le
monde pechora ce soir allez au lit alors
déjà merci le club une petite île sur
jean michel maire voilà c'est un peu
spécial antar yahia alors donc je veux
jean michel vous le savez aime beaucoup
son appareil génital et d'ailleurs il
n'a pu ne porte jamais de slip c'est un
secret pour personne
et aujourd'hui il avait il avait un trou
dans sa poche oui il a fait une petite
sieste
oui et aussi quand on dort genoux les un
canton se révèle finalement peut être un
peu enfin la mer où c'est beau ben moi
aussi je suis que les choses et si grave
o'shea s'est réveillé et comme il avait
un trou dans sa poche et bien sûr c'est
que c'est ressorti dans la poche nord
oui il a senti un appel d'air alors
alors sois rassuré l'instant a été
immortalisée en photo puisque c'est
photographique son portable
voilà merci donc et la photo dans ce
bois qui dit pas c'est que c'était la
poche arrière en plus
[Applaudissements]